[Music]
in awesome counting news awesome
submitted by King V juice yeah
who's that don't like a Hindu god or
something no he's a good guy pretty good
guy
v juice good human that's nasty
vigilante parents are facing charges
after tying up an alleged child predator
I saw this [ __ ] this morning not
mad at that I was like this this parent
these parents should get a trophy they
did like Chris Hansen's 2020 but topped
it and hogtied the [ __ ] pet oh that's
amazing
do a video yes awesome I need to see
this show it to me I don't know we're
talking about do you want the story
first of the the video okay it's awesome
why don't dish in the blurred his face
it's Daily Mail they they blur people's
maybe but even the mom's face was
blurred though here we go he come to my
house to meet my 13 year old daughter
her he wanted to be her first we've
tackled him and zaps trapped him and
called the police because earlier today
when I asked the police to come here for
this meet they said no what why would
the police is not because she's 13 and
said it was okay because I've been going
there for six weeks she would have
gotten a trophy was that full hands down
yeah does it look like it looked like he
got a spanking yeah so this takes place
in Canada out of all places and so
apparently this person this 28 year old
man was a family acquaintance and he was
texting this 13 year old they say it
always is right it's almost like a
family friend
what are the 30 liberal text facts I
don't know what she was texting back but
apparently she was [ __ ] down
she was enticing yeah she wanted him or
he wanted to be her first and she was
like [ __ ] yeah let's do it
so truly the 13 year old wanted to do
okay
so then yeah like the mom said in the
video she had been going to the police
station telling them for six weeks like
hey there's this predator that keeps
talking to my daughter be can you do
something about it and then the cop said
that they told her to not take matters
into her own hands that they would be
investigating it but they didn't do [ __ ]
what they're too busy investigating
maple syrup apparently he was under
investigation since March
so since March have been investigating
this dude and so this particular meet-up
she was telling the closet can you be
here he's gonna come and me to meet my
daughter the cops again said don't take
any matters into your own hands that's
when her and the stepdad the mom and the
stepdad hogtied the dude and started
filming and then when the cops arrived
they freed the man took him to the
hospital and hasn't still not been
charged yet with anything but then the
police detained the mom and the
stepfather for being investigated for
criminal charges including assault
causing bodily harm and forcible
confinement Wow I'd have to say this PC
Bobby by the way whose PC Bobby in
Canada they are [ __ ] I wouldn't say
that they're human beings but they're a
little loopy they're a little loopy
they have weird world laws there let's
protect the [ __ ] out of the criminals
that's Canadian law apparently there was
a Chinese man do you remember that baby
a Chinese man was on a Greyhound bus in
Canada and there was a white kid next to
him sleeping can't escape what I believe
and the Chinese man yeah Chinese man
decided to UM eat him oh yeah yeah he
had a psychotic break yeah any chop they
killed the baby I'm in the baby the kid
he mutilated on the bus so no one
noticed that bus stop everyone ran out
yeah whenever someone's eating somebody
I was wrong yeah that's my
he didn't have a stove there yeah I
thought I thought it was like a quiet
little cut and then everyone's like road
tripping they don't the Canada not only
let this man free but they allowed him
to change his identity and change his
name like the mob apparently saw the guy
at a mall oh my god shopping oh whatever
so gruesome that the guy who was first
on the scene the first responder offed
himself
yeah he could not deal with the with the
PTSD from seeing kidney here's another
great documentary called dear Zachary
Zachary is another case it's a great
documentary it's amazing another case in
Canada where they let a psychotic woman
right
who killed murdered a guy in America but
then she had his baby right and then she
she didn't get in trouble right and then
she was like there are all these laws in
Canada they let her walk around and she
decided to kill the baby as well you
know I mean even though all signs led to
the fact that this woman was deranged
yeah so Canada has some real loopy laws
that's what happens when liberals win
you know what that's that's how to
control my friend to because I'm a
liberal but I think that there needs to
be I feel like America has got we [ __ ]
up several times what do you think is
justice so let's say you got a 13 year
old daughter wah be good I mean I you
know and I I don't want to get in
trouble you know so I'm gonna just
really kind of just kind of scurry
around in your the land in Italy in my
land about 13 year old daughter in a
bikini laying on her bed waiting for
this 28 year old to come over and sure
legs are spread open right probably
you're right I mean you know I would I
would do the same as this these parents
did okay right but I would say to the
girl my daughter what are you talk when
you talk to me about yeah what are you
saying that you want to [ __ ] this guy
yeah yeah I mean she has a lot to do
with it too yeah I would have say this
is that traditional rape it's not
traditional rape and I also want to say
this uh-huh I like fresh food what does
that mean just I do want to throw that
out there well I like fresh food - yeah
she's she's just very difficult bait we
also have to find out how long this
communication has been going down
because there's such a thing like these
guys they're the [ __ ] groom kids like
there's that grooming that's involved or
though they're gonna say like yeah baby
they're gonna they're gonna want to
split us up and you know they're not
gonna believe in true love and so
they're predators yeah that's what
they're [ __ ] good at so you might not
think it's right because she's doing
that but you don't know what the other
dudes telling her on the other end she's
so influential impressionable and
probably gullible and doesn't know and
their own emotions and her body she
might not be the popular girl in school
and now like this other older guy that's
the semi-attractive now is like into her
and she's just like oh [ __ ] I like this
guy's parents miss step - yeah where did
they go these predators should be killed
is he working
what is how old's the guy 28 oh yeah
dude at 20 yeah hit see what she's into
him yeah that's gross
cuz he's like an older guy but he's not
too old like he's in his twenties that's
like [ __ ] a toddler dude yeah dude
I'm eating man and all the movies you
know like we can say like oh yeah she
knows what she's doing but does she
really if I was 13 and a 28 year old
woman want to [ __ ] me I'm [ __ ]
jailbait hell yeah I'm trying to get
that [ __ ] all day but if I was a 13
year old girl I don't know about that
Jerry Lee Lewis yeah she's married yes
thirteen your cousin 13 I'll cause oh my
god a cousin yeah and America was okay
with it
great balls of fire America was okay
with that want me wasn't that Elvis too
wasn't she hello young like 16 yeah yeah
I mean Mark Kelly and alia so what I'm
saying is that it just depends on
situations I guess you know the age is
arbitrary right I mean we all develop at
different rates but it really is it's
you know the guys should be it's against
the law that's number one and number two
arm
you should be how do you like your food
he should be I like it fresh but he I
think the problem is the cops why the
[ __ ] did the cops not help ya and why is
it the parents being being prosecuted
too well they did do illegal things they
can't hog-tie to do they can't lure them
into the house that's like about - well
they lured him into the house or
actually I don't know exactly what he
guy and said I read more into it but the
mom basically pretended to be the
daughter and started like flirting with
him and making him horny and [ __ ] and
then invited him to the house second
trip yeah oh I see so because of that
it's like oh I'm gonna get some plus I
so it wasn't like he broke in and then
they tapped oh no they were like
planning to meet but they were already
like flirting back and forth before that
so then she took over the account and
then started to pretend to be the
daughter and then she confronted him she
popped him in the face and then two guys
came up and that's what happened that's
a satisfying though it is it is it's
illegal but it's I think those type of
things shouldn't be illegal I think
those things should be honored so the
only thing that they wrote about the
long with the phone was that she said
I'm so glad I got my daughter's phone
and saw the message she did any grace so
yeah I didn't even know I could actually
call her sim to come and and get those
guys that's a dangerous oh man I just
hope that more people more parents would
do this kind of [ __ ] and what's up with
Canada
well widely wants you now like if
they're gonna get in trouble I would do
it though where she [ __ ] up is put it
all over the world and call the police
if you hog-tie the [ __ ] chop his
dick off and make him go home with a
bleeding ass dick do something you know
like what is he gonna do call the cops
yeah I try to rape this girl but their
parents cut my dick off probably some
people are spineless as [ __ ] yeah then
in Canada you'll probably still walk
free cuz he got his big top dog or maybe
the person that chopped off his dick
will go free I don't know like it's
weird out there oh maybe you got a
chocolate like chop his dick off and I
record a video hey what did you come
here for make them say that they're
coming here to rape your daughter
alright cool it for proof yeah for proof
so you also have proof for blackmail
at the end of the day it's a kid it's a
kid that doesn't know much you know
she's innocent right
right whether what
she texts or not and he's an adult and
it's against the law
it's morally wrong he goes against the
Bible I don't even think that's against
the Bible I think it's in the Bible it's
in the Bible I think they molest left
and right in the Bible statutory rape
totally okay in the Bible are not in the
Bible what I'm saying it's morally wrong
and I'm saying that my stance as Bobby
Lee the comedian is is that this person
should have been disintegrated with a
laser laser pistol
instantly disintegrate you know and I
made me impart were laughing you were
laughing too when I said fresh food
burlier and I was just making a joke and
that was just a joke you know I mean at
the end of the day the real is that this
person should be lasered and
disintegrated into nothingness
[Music]
Oh